do support Jim Crow If you're not eating
cookie dough
and does your desire to diet make you
want to race riot author Virginia Soul
Smith is stirring controversy and
probably a bucket of gravy
by claiming that the desire to be thin
stems from white supremacy
so let me get this straight the thin
ideal is definitely a white ideal
in the thin ideal is definitely a white
ideal if when we trace the history of
modern diet culture we really trace it
back in the United States to the end of
slavery so celebrating a thin white body
as the ideal body is a way to other and
demonize black and brown bodies bigger
bodies anyone who doesn't fit into that
Norm so this is really about maintaining
systems of white supremacy and
patriarchy
hahaha
what a horrible stupid no-good up thing
to say
excuse me you you are disgusting
you are disgusting
people got skinny as a celebration of
being white and demonizing blacks tell
that to President Taft
or the millions of white people who are
obese just like you Virginia yeah not
plus size obese
sorry it's not white people's fault you
can't stop stuffing your face with
donuts
you blame patriarchy no more like pastry
Archy
and we don't give a how plus size you
are you could eat a pickup truck full of
koala bears for all I care I don't care
because being fat isn't your problem
it's being stupid
you're telling
you're telling you're telling kids in
this day and age not to worry about
getting fat which is the cause of 300
000 preventable deaths a year you're
actually green lighting slow suicides
that end up killing the people you
pretend to defend oh so you're fat
because white people are racist no
you're actually the racist a big one
because
you assume that blacks can't eat better
or exercise self-control or just
exercise period
but just like your toilet after binging
on Taco Bell
you're fully
Julie this is like the most dangerous
stupid you know what I mean to say that
you can't control a preventable health
risk because it's based on the end of
slavery how Wicked is that no it's
disgusting I mean I do relate with her
on a couple things like I too would like
to be thin and I am a slave to children
but I mean how the hell does that make
us racist so it's like it absolutely
makes absolutely no sense and you know
what are they going to say next that
children are racist because they treat
their parents like slaves I don't know I
mean that's going to be about as stupid
as her claims are right now and she is a
white plump woman so I'm not quite even
sure where the hell she got this idea
well no that's almost all of these um no
I mean no no almost all of these
crackpot ideas come from white female
liberals no black person would ever a
black person hearing this would laugh
hysterically and just go you're nuts
and don't eat my nuts laughs
cat
yes you're a racist you're you are you
are the you know what by virtue of your
weight you are the probably the biggest
white supremacist ever to walk this
Earth
how dare you flaunt your racism what are
you a size zero
this one yes yes
I am uh and you know I think this woman
is being really mean to me
yep yep I she can do whatever she wants
yeah she can she can look however she
wants I don't care but for her to get
out there and the fact that nobody
questions these things and just
publishes them that to me is where it's
crazy this is from the article
she identifies as quote small fat
herself and advocated making the term
neutral as opposed to derogatory okay if
I were in this interview I would say
hold on a minute what what does that
mean yeah nobody ever says that anymore
as soon as you bring race into it or
phobia into it anything phobia people
are like uh-huh yeah uh-huh and then
that's how this done gets published yes
nobody actually believes this no nobody
can believe Nobody Does it make sense
she she gives you a point a and then she
gives you a point B and there's no way
that one gets to the other yes she's
like you're skinny and I'm not and
therefore you're a racist yeah yeah
I know it's amazing
right now there's about 4 000 dogs in
the city going like this
what is small fat small fat well let's
ask Joe
oh I I think I might be the heaviest
person on the panel thank you a small
fat is that something you get at
Starbucks I think yes this
um this I in in the oppression Olympics
she's in the decathlon where and I hate
to use a sports metaphor in this case
but it's it's the idea of like well I'll
combine these things to get myself the
most amount of sympathy that I can it's
nonsense fat people are not oppressed
I've been oppressed by fat people I've
been oppressed up against a window on a
flight to L.A by someone who was muffin
topping their way into my seat so it's
the ultimate first world problems this
isn't even this isn't even second world
problems yeah sorry Serbia you can't get
in on this yeah this is the idea that
you could say to someone
that the history of Oppression there
were no other oppressed groups that have
it the way fat people do because you get
to eat yeah no other press it's been
like oh we've been building this
railroad all day but the the lunch is
awesome yeah
so it's it's just nonsense and I hate to
say it like if you're if you're in this
situation the the
bad health effects of obesity are well
known and we've even just seen it with
covid exactly aside from age it was the
number one comorbidity so this is not
just something where we can say oh well
to each this is dangerous and this is
costing people's lives just like every
other Lefty intersectional thing like
defunding the police killed black people
pushing this stuff kills fat people
exactly no they they project these ideas
without carrying what kind of
consequences they are I can say that I
mean I've had weight issues I gain
weight and I lose weight I gain weight
and I lose weight you're always better
when you lose the weight and when you
gain the weight you're depressed you
know you're fat and you and but you
don't project that on other people you
go like I gotta fix this now you're
you've been you once weighed 500 pounds
and then you decided to lose weight and
look how successful you are now right
before you were a circus clown at the
carnival you're at the dunk tank
I I blanked out that period of my life
and we understand why it wasn't really
it was a humiliating experience I prefer
to pass over it yeah myself but you
you've written about this kind of like
it's not even woke isn't it anymore it's
just mental illness this is I mean we
had that as you were saying in the
covert pandemic when uh uh was it glamor
magazine do you remember how that cover
of a very large fat black woman and it
said this is healthy yeah that was the
cover and you're like no this is not
healthy this is like not healthy at any
time and it's especially not healthy
when it comes to covet but but but this
is just another example as you say in
your headlines the racialization of
everything right you can you can get on
NPR you can get academic funding if you
say I'd like to go from Plantation to my
current preoccupation and say
everything's racist it'll work and as
for this this ignoramus when she said
this did you notice that she did a
little smuggling trick there she said
she was talking about thin people and
fat people and then she just smoked
struggled in saying thin white bodies
yes I go oh but but you weren't talking
about white bodies you you so she says
thin whiteboards then there's fat black
bodies right and then well okay you've
created your dichotomy and now you'll
get another research Grant and you'll
get on NPR again I just think people
need to tell these people to go away
exactly they like getting in all of our
way up next Bears take a hike while bums
crap anywhere they like hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else